Rook to A1 and why is this so good for
black
apparently there's a ridiculous tactic
that's never going to happen with Knight
takes before if Magnus plays that move I
leave wait what's the point Knight 64
Knight he played it
I'm leaving oh
no
Bishop C4 Queen takes off three
and now Bishop D4 sets up the main
thread on G1 he's found that too and
Avid has to abandon the Knight
and that ends the combination
23 the queen has only one Escape square
and it's enough
Rook B2 and it's over
this was a masterpiece like we were
talking about how great some of the
other games were this one Sublime
that would have taken me 30 minutes and
there'd be absolutely no guarantee that
I would see that move Knight takes B4
are you kidding me and Bishop C4 would
have got